jean paul ii condamne solennellement
l'avortement c'est la première prise de
position importante du pape depuis son
élection
algérie à la veille des obsèques du
président boumédiène gérard ce bac
envoyé spécial d'antenne 2 analyse la
situation politique
un différend entre la france et
l'allemagne le système monétaire
européen peut être retardée temps doux
et pluvieux pour les derniers jours de
l'année les prévisions de laurent
broomhead bonsoir 7 6 et 2 ce sera le
tiercé du 3 janvier prochain pour
l'augmentation des carburants
ça a été décidé ce matin par le comité
des prix est annoncé cet après midi par
l'hôtel matignon
plus 7 centimes pour le super qui
passera donc cas de francs 75 dans la
région parisienne plus 6 centimes pour
l'ordinaire qui passe donc à deux francs
54 et + 2 centimes pour le fuel oil
domestiques des hausse un peu moins
importante que prévu cela est dû à la
cagnotte constituée par le gouvernement
en septembre dernier mais d où ce qu'il
ne faut pas confondre avec celle qui
interviendront à la mi février et qui
résultent elles de l'augmentation des
prix du pétrole décidée récemment par
les pays producteurs d'ailleurs le
premier ministre a précisé cet après
midi que les hausses de prix récemment
arrêtée par l'opep seront le moment venu
intégralement répercutée au stade du
détail et que ces eaux seront d'autant
plus limitées que le franc demeura faire
lé deuxième grands titres de l'actualité
de ce journal la déclaration du pape
jean paul ii fait aujourd'hui devant 600
médecins catholiques italiens c'est une
condamnation solennelle de l'avortement
en tant que médecin vous êtes des
ministres de la vie et non des
instruments de la mort a dit le pape
jean paul ii alors quand l'église saint
louis des français à rome une messe
d'intercession pour les victimes des
avortements étaient célébrées jean paul
ii s'adressait à 600 médecins
catholiques italiens le pape les mettait
en garde contre les puissants courants
d'opinion qui cherche à influencer de
toutes les façons les consciences
contribuant ainsi à des pratiques
contraires à l'éthique non seulement
chrétienne mais simplement
lurel fin de citation le souverain
pontife a recommandé à ses eaux
l'objection de conscience exprimant son
admiration pour ceux qui résistent aux
pressions ou flatterie jean paul ii
faisait allusion aux manifestations
récentes soutenu en italie par des
partis politiques des associations
féministes qui se sont élevés contre les
médecins refusant l'avortement
et les parloirs un premier commentaire
après cette prise de position du pape
trois réflexions d'abord cette
déclaration est à usage interne a été
fait devant des médecins catholiques
italiens or n'oublions pas que le pape
et l'évêque de rome et il le reprend à
son compte si je puis dire
la récente déclaration des évêques
italiens qui rappelait aux catholiques
de ce pays que s'il recourt à
l'avortement
eh bien ils risquaient l'excommunication
d'autre part on sait que les évêques
italiens et le parti démocrate chrétien
n'ont pas digéré la loi italienne sur
l'avortement qui est en application
depuis cette année et qu'ils essaient
ils ne ménagent pas leurs efforts en
tout cas pour essayer de l'abroger à à
l'aide d'un référendum
deuxièmement la position de jean paul ii
finalement est dans le droit chemin de
celle de paul 6 n'oubliez pas qu'à la
veille du débat parlementaire français
sur la loi sur l'avortement en 1975
le vatican avait publié un texte contre
l'avortement ce qui avait jeté une
certaine consternation dans certains
milieux catholiques france a précisément
quelle sera l'attitude des élèves
français d'après vous bien écouter les
élèves français jusqu'à présent
disons qu'ils étaient un peu embarrassé
ils sont certes contre l'avortement mais
il insiste sur tout à fait autre chose
ils disent on rend libre l'avortement
d'accord n'ont fait bien mieux
d'examiner les causes notamment et je
voulais vous dire en plus que cette
condamnation de jean paul ii confirmé un
peu ce que l'on n'avait ressenti de sa
personnalité
sur le plan du style c'est un novateur
mais sur le plan du dogme et de la
morale c'est un conservateur
on savait qu'il serait intransigeant
donc cette nouvelle prise de position
aussi catégorique de jean paul ii risque
également de jeter une certaine
consternation dans certains pays
libéraux ou non un avortement existent
déjà comme c'est le cas notamment en
france je dois ajouter que les évêques
français ont décidé de publier très
prochainement un texte sur l'avortement
sans doute qui reprendra la condamnation
de jean paul ii ça ne fait aucun doute
même mais peut-être avec des termes
beaucoup plus nuancée
je rappelle qu'en france depuis 1975 une
loi régit ce problème de l'avortement
elle permet cette loi dans certaines
conditions bien précises le recours à
l'avortement thérapeutique
ce qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'elle a été
votée pour cinq ans et qu'elle devra
être
ré examiné par le parlement à la fin de
l'année prochaine à propos de l'église
sachez que dans leur grande majorité 79%
les français croient à l'avenir de la
foi c'est ce qui ressort entre autres
d'un sondage ifop réalisé pour
l'hebdomadaire la vie l'église pour les
français est en résumé rich divisé
conservatrice et son rôle est de prendre
position sur les problèmes sociaux plus
que sur la morale personnelle
il y aura dix mille jeunes ce soir à
notre dame de paris pour une veillée de
prière ils viennent de pratiquement tous
les pays d'europe
et cette grande réunion organisée par
les responsables de l'abbaye de taizé a
pour thème le partage avec comme point
de départ pour cette soirée
l'expérience d'une vingtaine de jeunes
partis vivre plusieurs semaines dans les
bidonvilles du kenya en afrique qu'ils
ont raconté leur expérience à philippe
harrouard nous sommes allés givre dans
un grand bidonville de nairobi
on l'appelle matar et valait un
bidonville et 100000 habitants vivant
sur un espace très réduit et on a voulu
être au milieu de ces pauvres
comme un signe de partage et on était de
tous les continents et pas pour aller
vivre une mission mais être avec eux et
partager leurs conditions de vie
partager c'est pour cela que ces dix
mille jeunes sont réunis pour 48 heures
a pas les églises de la capitale se sont
transformés en centres d'accueil pour
les recevoir et les envoyer dans des
familles ils vont d'abord prendre
conscience de la vie des plus pauvres
qui a été partagé par leurs camarades et
à travers leurs réflexions leurs
conclusions
ce sont tous les sans voix de la terre
qui vont pouvoir s'exprimer l'écoutent
précède le partage je n'avais jamais vu
de pareil cas pas dans mon pays
d'abord tous les problèmes que ça posait
des violences et
du d'alcoolisme et qui réduisent l
ensemble de la population à la peur et
la frustration si bien que les gens qui
vivent en aérobie ne voulait pas
s'installe les visées vous courrez un
grand risque à la vivre dans ces
quartiers on se disait aussi on ne peut
pas partager la vie des gens du kenya
sans partage mais aussi leurs risques
incertitudes quand il s'agit de vraiment
s'assurer une vie il y a une volonté de
vivre qui est absolument extraordinaire
donc il ya une attente par rapport à
l'avenir
on voudrait sortir les conditions s'il
n'y a pas une acceptation jean fataliste
tandis que je trouve que c'est souvent
en occident qu'il n'ya plus d'attendre
envie d'une ville comme celle qu'on a
vécue maîtres et valets je n'ai connu
beaucoup c'est pas seulement le matin
révélée mais peut-être pour nous aussi
convie les consuls dncd de faire prendre
conscience aux gens des citations qui
existent et qui nous appellent à faire
quelque chose
frère roger le prieur de taizé qui avait
pu lui aussi dans le bidonville invitera
tous ces jeunes chrétiens à la prière
qui selon lui devrait aboutir à
l'étonnement d'un amour amour envers les
déshérités et j bien constater que dans
l'histoire des hommes
quelques femmes quelques hommes répartis
à travers le monde peut par la prière
par un engagement très très fort entre
authentique pour dieu renverser le cours
des déterminismes l'histoire et
réinventer le monde sait cela que
j'attendais des jeunes de l'afrique de
dix mille jeunes venant de toute
l'europe
ce soit au ray et resteront à paris de
trois jours c'est cela que j'attends
d'eux qu'ils réinventent le monde dans
la prière parce qu'ils vont une source
qu'est lieu le christ l'algérie après la
mort du président boumédiène maintenant
toute la journée alors que de véritables
scènes d'hystérie collective se
produisait autour du palais du peuple à
alger
là où repose le corps du président
algérien les messages de condoléances
venant du monde entier continuait
d'arriver dans la capitale algérienne
télégramme de moscou et de pékin du
vatican de washington des nations unies
la plupart d'entre eux soulignait la
personnalité hors du commun du président
boumédiène il insistait sur le rôle
déterminant qu'il a joué dans la marche
de l'algérie vers son indépendance
c'est monsieur jean françois poncet le
ministre français des affaires
étrangères qui conduira demain vendredi
la délégation française aux funérailles
du président algérien houari boumédiène
sera enterrée près de la tombe
d'abdelkader les dizaines de milliers de
personnes sont attendues pour ces
obsèques où l'on risque fort de revoir
les scènes qui se sont déroulées
aujourd'hui à alger gérard sebag
tout au long de la journée des milliers
d'algériens venus à pied
individuellement ou en cortège ont rendu
un dernier hommage au président
boumédiène dont le catafalque est exposé
au palais du peuple
des scènes étonnantes de pleurs de
femmes et d'hommes souvent mal
indéniablement cette sympathie et même
ce désespoir montre que les algériens
sont désemparés après cette disparition
ces marques d'affection à l'égard de
celui qui gouverna l'algérie avec une
forte prime pendant près de 14 ans
peuvent étonner mais beaucoup
d'algériens dans cette foule m'ont
affirmé
même si certains ne l'aimé pas il le
respecte car c'était un grand président
et c'est sans doute grâce à lui que
l'algérie ne s'est pas déchiré après
l'indépendance
pour l'instant et sa pratique au jusqu'à
demain soir afin d'étrenner rails du
président vous mediène aucun homme
politique n'accepte de parler rien ne
doit pas entacher la dignité de ces au
frais cependant après ses obsèques
il faudra envisager l'avenir et la
succession bien que tous ici s'accordent
à rappeler les mérites et les qualités
de l'oeuvre du président boumédiène avec
une sorte de fierté nationale
il ne fait pas de doute que tous
souhaitent un après boumédiène différent
ce n'est pas l'option socialiste du pays
qui sera remise en cause
mais l'exercice solitaire du pouvoir les
algériens souhaitent un cadre politique
plus démocratique où toutes les
tendances pourront s'exprimer
pourtant il faudra faire un choix pour
la présidence
on pense que monsieur ya rien oui
responsables actuels du fln a le plus de
chances d'être désigné pour succéder à
boumédiène mais il devra partager son
pouvoir avec d'autres membres du conseil
de la révolution qui seront nommés soit
vice président ou premier ministre
la constitution sera ainsi respectée
mais en réalité le pouvoir sera assurée
par un directoire ou figureront
notamment le colonel chebli le chef de
l'armée et monsieur bouteflika l'actuel
ministre des affaires étrangères mais
pour certains cette solution ne sera que
la transition de la transition actuelle
le temps que l'un de ces trois hommes
sortent des rampes l'homme boumédiène
est mort mais la révolution de
boumédiène restera c'est le grand titre
sur huit colonnes d'un des principaux
quotidiens d'alger ce matin un quotidien
qui publie également l'appel au peuple
algérien lancé hier par le conseil de la
révolution
ce dernier le conseil de la révolution
s'engage à poursuivre l'action
entreprise par le chef de l'état
algérien
que ce soit sur le plan extérieur ou sur
le plan intérieur
précisément je pense qu'il est
intéressant de tracer un portrait rapide
de l'algérie tels que le successeur du
président boumédiène va la trouver
après son élection bernard benyamin
c'est un pays aux richesses
exceptionnelles mais peut-être mal
exploité que vont trouver le
les successeurs de houari boumédiène
premier tableau la campagne algérienne à
l'indépendance du pays
l'agriculture fournissez 21 % de la
richesse nationale
aujourd'hui 7% le président algérien le
reconnaissait lui même la réforme
agraire n'a pas été un succès les
coopératives agricoles n'ont pas donné
les résultats que l'on espérait
conséquence l'algérie exportatrices
agricole en 1960 a dû multiplier les
importations de biens alimentaires
cela représente aujourd'hui 20% du coût
de ces achats à l'étranger
conséquence aussi les algériens des
villes ont d'énormes difficultés
d'approvisionnement il n'est pas rare
qu'un produit de base comme la pomme de
terre ou la tomate par exemple
disparaissent purement et simplement
pendant des semaines
deuxième tableau l'appareil industriel
c'est le grand succès de houari
boumédiène à l'indépendance l'industrie
fournit ses 24 % de la richesse
nationale
aujourd'hui 57 % et c'est vrai que les
investissements n'ont pas été ménagés
pour valoriser toutes les ressources du
pays
phosphate charbon faire et surtout
pétrole et gaz naturel
les chiffres sont éloquents l'algérie
est pratiquement le premier exportateur
mondial de gaz naturel
ces réserves la classe au quatrième rang
mondial
et pourtant malgré cette réussite malgré
ses richesses l'inflation et le chômage
ne cesse de monter entre 15 et 20% pour
ces dernières années plus grave encore
les usines ne tournent pas à plein elle
n'utilise aujourd'hui que 30 % de leurs
capacités de production
voilà en gros l'algérie de l'après
boumédiène la seule véritable question
d'ordre extérieur étant de savoir si le
pays continuera à graviter dans l'orbité
de l'union soviétique ou si au contraire
il s'ouvrira au monde occidental
à l'occasion des obsèques du président
boumédiène antenne 2 diffusera après
demain une émission spéciale
particulièrement destiné à la population
algérienne résidant en france
samedi 30 décembre de 11h30 à 12h15
antenne 2 présentera un résumé des
manifestations de vendredi à alger
l'europe monétaire maintenant la france
tire le signal d'alarmé
attention vient de rappeler le
gouvernement français si un accord n'est
pas intervenu au niveau européen d'ici
le 1er janvier sur le problème des
montants compensatoires
il se pourrait fort que l'entrée en
vigueur du système monétaire européen
soit retardé vous savez que ces montants
compensatoires sont une sorte de prime à
l'exportation pour les producteurs
agricoles des pays à monnaie forte comme
l'allemagne fédérale
une sorte de pénalisation pour les
agriculteurs français
or lors de la dernière réunion de
bruxelles où le système monétaire
européen avait été mis au point
il avait été dit qu'un accord devait
intervenir entre l'allemagne fédérale et
la france précisément à propos de ces
montants compensatoires
il est de 10 en effet au niveau des
chefs d'état lors du conseil européen
que les montants compensatoires
monétaire qui naîtrait puisque c'est un
mal hélas nécessaire devaient être
supprimés dans le temps les ministres de
l'agriculture ont voulu confirmer cette
notion de temps et c'est là qu'il ya
aujourd'hui un blocage surtout un
blocage je dirais entre la france et
l'allemagne la france décidée à
appliquer totalement le serpent
monétaire européen et en tirer toutes
les conséquences pour ne plus laisser
isoler l'agriculture par rapport aux
autres secteurs de l'économie européenne
et de l'économie nationale
mais alors ce blocage va durer combien
de temps le temps qu'il faudra pour que
nous arrivions à une solution positive
et que nous changions nos mécanismes en
matière de montants compensatoires
monétaire sinon si nous n'utilisons pas
ce levier ce fait nouveau cette chance
nouvelle que le serpent monétaire
européen
nous ne changerons rien dans les années
qui viennent
car changé pour beaucoup de pays
difficile il faut donc utiliser ce
levier pour en finir avec les montants
compensatoires monétaire dans l'avenir
et pour qu'une solution durable puisse
être trouvée le 10 janvier le premier
j'espère le 15 février si nous n'y
arrivons pas le 15 janvier un télégramme
maintenant l'actualité à l'étranger la
compagnie aérienne espagnole iberia a
décidé d'acheter quatre airbus livrables
à partir de 1980 et elle a pris des
options pour quatre autres appareils
c'est le 20ème clients de ce biréacteur
moyen courrier émeutes permanente en
iran avec de nouvelles violences dans
les rues de téhéran aujourd'hui quatre
secteurs clés de l'économie iranienne
sont maintenant touchées par les grèves
le pétrole les douanes les banques et
l'aviation civile en images la situation
des réfugiés vietnamiens la réouverture
des temples d'angkor vat au cambodge et
l'arrivée mouvementée à taiwan d'un
émissaire américain des cailloux et des
oeufs pourris pour le secrétaire d'état
adjoint américain warren christopher en
visite à taïwan
accompagné de l'ambassadeur des états
unis à formose monsieur christopher
était venu examiner sur place les
conséquences de la rupture des relations
diplomatiques entre taiwan et les usa
culture qui a fait suite à la
normalisation des rapports entre
washington et pékin les deux hommes ont
été légèrement blessés par des éclats
d'obus
premier voyage organisé aux temples
d'angkor vat pour un groupe de
journalistes et d'agents de voyages
étrangers
les quarante privilégiés qui ont
effectué cette visite ont pu constater
que les temples n'avait été que
légèrement endommagée par la guerre
fermé depuis 1970 ils devraient être ré
ouvert prochainement aux touristes au
départ de la thaïlande les autorités de
phnom penh en prouvant ainsi leur pays
au monde extérieur à un moment où le
régime connaît de graves difficultés
notamment avec le vietnam
situation dramatique pour les 2700
réfugiés vietnamiens du qi gong bloqués
depuis six jours dans les eaux
internationales face à hong kong
le gouvernement de la colonie
britannique refuse toujours l'entrée du
port au cargo battant pavillon panaméen
et à ses passagers
situation semblable pour un autre cargo
immobilisé depuis hier devant manille
avec là aussi deux mille sept cents
réfugiés vietnamiens dans les deux cas
la procédure d' aide internationale
semble bloquée puisque en principe elle
ne commence qu'après l'arrivée à terre
des réfugiés retour en france avec la
fin à longwy en meurthe et moselle de
l'opération blocus de la ville par les
syndicats et les habitants qui
protestaient contre les suppressions
d'emplois dans le groupe usinor
une grande manifestation est prévue à
nancy pour le 4 janvier prochain
une trentaine de militants communistes
de la section précisément usinor à
longwy sont entrés dans le bureau du pdg
du groupe sidérurgique cet après midi à
paris la délégation a demandé à être
reçus par le pdg qui était absent les
militants ont distribué des tracts
il n'y a pas eu d'incident conférence de
presse cet après midi à paris de
philippe riès journaliste de
l'hebdomadaire informations ouvrière de
tendance trotskiste il avait été
emprisonné en pologne puis expulsé c'est
une machination mon expulsion est une
machination politique visant
l'opposition en l'opposition au régime
de varsovie a expliqué cet après midi
philippe briat ce monsieur michel
crépeau le président du mouvement des
radicaux de gauche a souhaité lui aussi
cet après midi que les partis de gauche
saisissent l'occasion des jeux
olympiques de moscou en 1980 pour
obtenir de la part de l'union soviétique
des assouplissements concernant les
droits de l'homme sondage de fin d'année
publié dans les hebdomadaires
celui d'abord réalisé par l'institut
harris sur la natalité en france 39% des
jeunes françaises de 18 à 24 ans
souhaite avoir trois enfants ou plus il
ya des publié ce sondage dans enfin
magazine on va venge parmi les femmes
qui ont déjà deux enfants 12% seulement
d'entre elles souhaitent en avoir un
troisième enfin sondage publié par paris
match à propos des événements marquants
de 1978 en france et dans le monde
selon l'ifop les français ont classés
dans l'ordre d'importance
ans la marée noire de l'amoco cadiz en
bretagne la liberté des prix
troisièmement les difficultés de
manufrance et quatrièmement le massacre
de guyane a pas puisque j'en suis à
parler des hebdomadaires
je veux saluer la naissance d'un nouveau
confrère le nouveau footy un petit
magazine destiné aux enfants et aux
adolescents fous de football voilà je
vais maintenant me tourner vers notre
spécialiste en sondages et plus tôt en
prévision mais cela concerne la météo
cette fois puisqu'il s'agit de laurent
broomhead vous allez nous parler laurent
de la couleur du temps avec un blizzard
haut redoute qui inquiète les vacanciers
qui sont à la neige en cependant
absolument le temps doux et pluvieux va
continuer dans les prochains jours la
photographie prise par le satellite
meteosat ce matin même nous montre
plusieurs paquets de nuages en rouge ou
en gris foncé au nord d'abord de la
france ceux qui sont les nuages qui sont
passés au dessus de nous hier est tout à
fait en bas à gauche qui sont passés
aujourd'hui toute cette pluie n'est pas
bien sûr fait pour améliorer le sort de
ce cure car non seulement la neige ne
tombe plus à basse altitude comme ici
dans les pyrénées mais en plus c'est la
tendance à fond car bien souvent le
thermomètre ne descend guerre de toute
la journée en dessous de zéro degré dans
les pyrénées la couche de neige se situe
entre 15 et 30 centimètres entre 1800 et
2400 mètres d'altitude dans les
prochains jours le grand cyclone qui
pond qui est au dessus de l'atlantique
continuera à propulser au dessus de
notre pays du temps pluvieux mais l'air
froid qui règne au dessus du nord de
l'europe va descendre progressivement si
bien que ce temps doux n'est pas éternel
alors demain et bien encore donc le
temps doux lait l'apli qui a traversé la
france aujourd'hui donneront encore
quelques averses sur l'est et le sud-est
le matin puis sur l'ensemble du pays se
généralisera un temps variable avec des
nuages quelques averses surtout
l'après-midi dans la moitié nord du pays
et des sites là si tout de même belle
dans le sud
samedi maintenant et bien de la pluie le
matin sur l'extrême nord du pays le pays
de caux la flandre et jusqu'à la
belgique
et puis le reste du pays lui sera
balayée par une vague de pluies qui
commencera le matin sur l'ouest puis qui
progressivement se décalera vers l'est
pour arriver jusqu'au sud est dans la
soirée contes trouvant et bien ma foi
ils resteront parfois assez fort dans la
journée et en prenant ces deux jours
près des côtes de la manche et de
l'atlantique attention donc à la tempête
voilà
merci laurent broomhead dans l'actualité
de ce jeudi 28 décembre il y avait
également cet incident arrivé plus tôt
cet accident arrivait un habitant de la
meurthe-et-moselle il est resté 18
heures coincé dans sa voiture blessée
qui s'appelle monsieur dutordoir il est
père de cinq enfants il a raté un virage
en 30 chez lui après son travail
sa voiture est tombée en contrebas de la
route cela s'était passé à 19 heures
mardi soir il a été retrouvé le
lendemain à 13 heures il a été
hospitalisé
et puis il ya également la mort d'un des
plus grands propriétaires de chevaux de
trot monsieur henri levesque dont le nom
était associé au nom de celui de
nombreux cracks tel massina oscar
airelles et adolphe du vivier il vient
de mourir d'une crise cardiaque à l'âge
de 70 ans
enfin il ya l'inculpation du président
de la croix rouge des hauts-de-seine
pour escroquerie il aurait détourné une
somme allant de 100 à 200 millions de
centimes au préjudice de la croix rouge
il a été écroué et puis dans l'actualité
d'antenne de cette fois vous êtes très
nombreux à suivre sur notre chaîne le
feuilleton gaston fébus de bernard
borderie avec jean claude drouot les
deux derniers épisodes de cette série
seront diffusés demain soir et samedi à
20h30 mais saviez vous que ce feuilleton
est tiré de deux gros livre deux gros
volumes les voici écrit par myriam et
gaston de béarn
un grand roman historique où gaston
fébus compte deux fois et prince de
béarn est égal à sa légende
dans ce temps-là tu vois durera toujours
restant éparses mais comme sa petite
éternité quand on lit vos livres sur
fébus on a du mal à croire que ce prince
fut aussi brillant en caucus il est trop
beau pour être vrai comment ça il est
plus que vos passes en plus de sa beauté
décrite parfois ça c'est ce que disait
france chargé didier chevalier et des
princes et des rois mais jamais je
n'envie qui fait du cygne obsa tueur de
si merveilleuse prestance il avait le
visage coloré rieurs des yeux amoureux
il parlait amoureusement aux gens est
alors aux femmes c'est formidable
plaisait aux femmes
d'où vient cette passion de ce bus à
vous entendre on croirait un peu vivant
mais c'est mon mari qui m'a fait
connaître qu'il l'a fait aimer parce que
il en descend des evaux cause des
descendait des souverains de béarn et
dans ma famille c'était le grand ancêtre
plus d'henri iv
ouais c'est la fortune air france donc
voilà on sécurité si vous mettez moi de
rejoindre les troupes que j'ai abandonné
pour ne pas trop couper
merci mon cousin je dois la vie et les
morts de critiques en dirons nous ces
quelques milliers d'archers toute la
chevalerie française est ce que fait
plus ce n'est pas avant tout le pressent
de la différence le prince du contraste
il était vassal du roi de france mais
souverain dans son pays le béarn
il était gai riez mais diplomates ils
étaient seigneur mais accessible aux
humbles il était à l'image de ces
montagnes le ciel des pyrénées mais
jamais si proches de leur âge que
lorsque le soleil brille très fort et
tout est en lui comme les torrents les
torrents qui emporte tout dévastateurs
comme l'orage qu'il soit l'équipe
brillait c'est le soleil qui consume
voilà phoebe c'est le lion c'est le
fauve kaeslin qui fait la patte de
velours et petit sort ses griffes d'un
coup c'est ça qui plaît beaucoup aux
femmes
est ce que vous disiez que je fais plus
est un personnage moderne à ses proches
de certains régionaliste actuelle par
exemple très très ils étaient ils
étaient un grand démocrate
il était très proche de son petit but
est toujours le bonheur de son peuple
mais alors des environs et devant les
seigneurs qui veulent bien imposer alors
là
une sauvage de vie est traitable les
voit ici tu n'es plus sainement compté
deux fois mais une reine la reine du
béarn
vous laissez pas impressionner par ce
panel par cette cour souvenez vous
toujours que si le roi possède cette
puissance est un nouveau genre de ces
provinces qu'il la doit à ianu surtout
les béarnais que reste-t-il de l'oeuvre
de gaston fébus aujourd'hui son livre de
la chasse son livre des horizons mais
dans la mémoire du peuple dans la
mémoire collective
rien rien il y à des béarnais qui n'y a
même où se trouve sa statue dans le parc
du château de pau c'est injuste c'est
très injuste et ingrat et c'est ce qui
fait naître beaucoup mon mari parce que
gaston fébus pour sonder à passer son
bep en c'était gaston fait dispensable
et mcc a préféré se laisser jetés au
cachot par le roi jean le bon plutôt que
d'aligner la l'indépendance de ces
dernières oui c'est injuste
il me reste à vous parler d'un des
événements les plus plus important la
journée à savoir l'élection de miss
france qui se déroule ce soir dans un
grand hôtel parisien
toutes les provinces et toutes les
grandes villes dont le béarn ont fait
monter à paris leurs plus belles
représentantes qui aura la couronne
réponse vers 23h45 dans le dernier
journal berner claude en attendant ce
douloureux suspense je vous souhaite une
très belle soirée sur antenne 2